every time we've talked about primary challenges
to Donald Trump in 2020 I've been super clear
that those challenges are not going to succeed
in the sense of Donald Trump is going to be
the Republican nominee unless he bails out.
But I have said that the primary challenges
could still damage Trump and even a point
or two taken from Trump in some states is
all it would take for an independent, uh,
a Republican primary challenger who chooses
to run as an independent in November of 2020
to take a state or two from Donald Trump and
push it towards the Democratic challenger.
And that could actually turn the election.
Now, clearly the democratic, I'm sorry, the
Republican Party is worried about this because
they've now started canceling primaries and
caucuses to protect Donald Trump and to prevent
anyone from getting any attention or momentum.
Now, Trump loyalists have gotten into the
system in South Carolina and Nevada, Arizona
and Kansas at minimum.
And they are moving forward on canceling primaries
altogether, which is not very democratic.
Wouldn't the right thing to do be to let the
primaries happen.
Let Republican voters confirm that they want
Trump to be their nominee.
Trump says he is 94% support from the Republicans.
That's not true.
It's more like 80% but 80% is still more than
enough to win primaries except that that other
20% might be invigorated by those primaries
and vote for those primary challengers in
November if they run as independent or as
right in candidates in a way that it could
threaten Donald Trump in the general.
Now the Trump team is saying this is totally
normal.
This is fine.
There are many other examples in history when
primaries have been canceled, when there been
an incumbent president up for reelection,
but that is extremely deceptive because the
primaries that were previously canceled were
almost exclusively canceled because there
were no challengers, so there was no point
in having the primary when only the incumbent
is interested in running.
This is a very different situation where you
have multiple primary challengers, Joe Walsh,
William Weld.
There's a third one that now I'm forgetting.
Uh, and one fifth of Republican's disapprove
of Donald Trump.
So this is a very different scenario.
Now a somewhat asked Donald Trump on Monday,
would he participate in debates against these
challengers?
And he said, quote, I don't know them.
I would say this, they are all at less than
1% I guess it's a publicity stunt.
We just got a little while ago a poll showing
94% popularity or approval within the Republican
Party.
So to be honest, I'm not looking to get them
any credibility.
They have no credibility.
Now again, Trump's wrong.
It's about 80% of Republicans that approve
of the job he's doing, not 94%, but this is
how they win.
They cancel primaries, they Gerrymander, they
suppress votes by closing down polling places
and purging voter rolls.
They have no interest in genuinely protecting
our election systems from foreign interference.
And they even welcome it.
And then they blame Democrats of doing all
the same things and they spend millions on
real witch hunts, like the election integrity
commission or whatever it was that it was
called, which found nothing.
They've been cheating to win for years.
It is not going to stop for sure unless Donald
Trump has removed because we'll have a census
in 2020, which will then be used by these
same republicans to make it even worse and
then it'll get even uglier.
And I forgot to mention, by the way, gaslighting
constantly by demonizing those evil undocumented
immigrants too, it's important not to forget
that since that's a key part of their strategy,
they say that they're all for freedom and
democracy as long as it's their candidate
in the way that they want it and the people
voting that they want to see voting period.
Otherwise Freedom and democracy always take
a back seat to morality or simplicity or expediency
or whatever they can site at the time to justify
their behavior.
And we are seeing it again as the primaries
that Republicans should be holding are getting
canceled, uh, in growing numbers, which we
will continue to track.
Not Surprising, not surprising, but important
to understand that this is happening.